the vague ramaswamy issued a statement
three hours ago and just announced he's
filed a lawsuit against the U.S
Department of Justice for his failure to
respond to his foia request to uncover
what was officials including Joe Biden
communicated to Merrick Garland and Jack
Smith about uh let me read it about
um
uh about the unprecedented indictment in
the classified documents case of former
U.S president and one of Biden's
political opponents in the 2024
presidential election I'm also filing a
separate foia request with the doj to
uncover any similar Communications
relating to the just issued January 6
Trump indictment we should demand
accountability and transparency in USV
Alvarez Supreme Court held the political
candidates have First Amendment right to
knowingly make inaccurate statements if
you're going to indict a former
president and leading presidential
candidate it better not be based on
unprecedented precedented legal Theory
further it's much more than a stretch to
call something criminal if someone is
seeking legal counsel from their own
lawyers Jack Smith has created a
dangerous precedent by criminalizing the
behavior of Trump's lawyers who offer
them legal advice labeling them
co-conspirators instead this jeopardizes
the future of our legal system if we
fail to admit the truth January 6 will
just be a preview of far worse to come
we must reunite this country but the
path forward will not be easy I want to
play the video uh I assume it's probably
a different statement but let's uh let's
play it it's another sad moment in our
country's history the 45th president of
the United States Donald Trump has yet
again been indicted by the Biden doj a
political party in power that is now
repeatedly using police force to indict
and arrest and potentially eliminate its
political opponents from competition
this is a politicized prosecution it is
a political persecution through
prosecution now in a third indictment
just in a matter of months against the
person who is still at present the lead
contender in the Republican primary for
U.S president
I want to be very clear I am running for
U.S president in that same Republican
primary it would be easier for me if
Donald Trump were eliminated from
competition that's not how I want to win
this is not about politics to me this is
about first principles we do not want to
become a country where the party in
power is able to use banana
republic-like tactics to eliminate its
political opponents
you know I'm sad to say that's exactly
where we are
the allegations in this indictment fall
flat it is wrong and Incorrect and
inaccurate to place blame for what
happened on January 6th at the feet of
Donald Trump
I said this at the time I've said it
ever since then I continue to say it
today
I would not have made the same judgments
that Donald Trump did in how he handled
that day
but that's different from saying that he
committed a crime he did not he
specifically told the protesters that
day to behave peacefully the first
amendment in this country gives
political protesters the ability to
express themselves and their opinions
freely
Donald Trump was not responsible for
what happened on January 6th you want to
know what was responsible I said this in
the days after January 6 2021 just as I
say it today
systematic pervasive censorship in this
country
that was after a year where we had told
people across this nation that you had
to stay locked down in your house in
your basement and shut up sit down do as
you're told if you question that you're
racist you're anti-science your social
media accounts were silenced you had to
stay home and lock down unless you were
part of BLM or antifa in which case it
was perfectly fine to roam the streets
of this country and burn many of them
down
that was the double standard that then
applied and said that if you said the
virus originated in a lab in Wuhan you
were again a racist and had your
internet accounts shut down you were
then told you had an election where you
could express yourself to put the right
person in charge of fixing these
problems and instead your accounts were
suppressed if you sent a mere message
saying that the hunter Biden laptop
story from the New York Post was real
you had your accounts locked even the
New York Post had its own account locked
and if you repeatedly then tell people
they cannot speak that is when they
scream if you repeatedly tell people
they cannot scream that is when they
tear things down and I think we are
making a grave mistake in this country
by trying to pin the blame for that at
the feet of one man
if we refuse to learn our mistakes from
from our mistakes in the past we are
doomed to suffer an even worse fate in
the future I worry that will create a
country where January 6 2021 was a
friendly parlay compared to what's
actually to come I'm running for
president to make sure we don't March
towards some kind of national divorce
but the first and most important step
that we as candidates can take in this
race is to speak and speak forcefully on
the side of principle to say that even
if we're competing against Donald Trump
as I am I do not want to see him
eliminated from competition using these
politicized tactics it is wrong for our
country it is wrong for our future I
call on my fellow candidates to condemn
it and I call on President Biden to do
the right thing and drop these
politicized charges that's going to be a
first step towards uniting our country
so did uh just uh step into second place
in the Republican primary yes dude I
hope so holy smokes that was that was
really well done he did the exact same
thing I mean not the exact same thing
when uh the Mar-A-Lago raid happened I
mean this guy is a winner right here and
you where's Rhonda Santos's video
where's that at where is him condemning
this um I'm not gonna you know I I I'll
try and avoid comparing him let's just
like that was a very very well done
video that's professional he's just
talking to the camera I don't think
there's a script there I mean I'm just
looking at something the whole
production and I'm like this guy knows
part way through I was like I got to see
him and Obama get together and talk
geopolitics because this guy is the
president this is the guy he is the
right wing version of Obama but I think
he's actually actually genuine I think
that's the big difference but the way
that he is able to word things it's a
talent I mean he is very gifted he's a
businessman just like Trump is he's an
outsider and I can see why people see
him as a threat what else he is his
family is Indian and I don't I'm not big
into identity politics but you want to
talk about an ally in the 21st century
India it's the United States and India
if you're concerned about China
and communism you want India India is
the final piece of that if India sides
with the Communist Party Asia is a
deafening Roar if India and the United
States are Allied that could be one of
the most powerful peace bringing uh
unions in the world totally here yeah
Trump uh had a meeting was it Modi at
the time and Trump they love Trump but
vivek's an American citizens no his
parents were born in India I know but he
was born yeah but those as I said it's
his parents he's got Indian Heritage his
parents were from India and I'm not into
the identity stuff A white guy from
South Dakota could be a better Indian
Diplomat you know than Vivek but his
parents are India I'll tell you he's
Hindu like this is a good opportunity to
Bridge and blend some gaps I've had
people say they don't trust him or
whatever but I'm like the dude sat down
in front of me and outright said he
thinks there should be some kind of
Civic test for people to get the right
to vote amazing and I'm just like I
agree with you we've talked about that
on the show but the idea that someone
running for office would say something
like that that that's like
every advisor to be like no no no don't
say that because you're gonna lose
you're going to lose voters in this
demographic or that demographic and he
was like sits back and he's like I don't
know they're probably getting mad at me
for saying this but we got to have some
kind of uh test or or qualifier for
voting in this country yes I love the
fact that he's at least thinking about
the ramifications of an ignorant
population being manipulated by
you know social media companies
corporations the government itself
whatever I love the fact that he's like
look people are going to be manipulated
to some degree so we need to do what we
can to make sure that the people that
are voting actually care about voting
because I've honestly I truly believe
that there are far more people that will
get upset if you tell them that we're
going to take away the right of your
your right to vote then we'll go out and
vote right like there are way more
people that are like I want the right
even though I have never and will never
get my ass off the couch and go out and
the simple idea that anybody can vote is
actually absurd the fact that you don't
have to take just a simple civics class
so you can at least prove that you know
the bare minimum about government yeah
people that you're voting in is insane
to me I don't know how and I so I'm not
going to make a prescription as to the
way to
ensure that the people voting and not
only have a stake and and and have
actual uh you know concern about the the
policies and stuff Beyond just voting
for you know to put their hands in the
government's Pockets
um but
the idea that you need to have some kind
of qualification or at least prove that
you have that you care about where the
country's going not not just
you care about being able to stick your
hand in the government's coffers I think
that's something that's worth talking
about let's take a look at the betting
odds here it's from Real Clear Politics
RCP betting average and you can see Rama
Swami since he entered has just been
climbing and climbing and climbing he's
currently at 14 cents in the prediction
markets Donald Trump has seen a major
spike but interestingly when they
started tracking this in January Ron
DeSantis was in the lead
that means if you were to have bought
shares on the prediction Market of Ronda
Sanders in January you'd have lost
you're hurting you're you're you I mean
you're we're talking 80 of of of your of
your bet
even Donald Trump improved but but I
think ramaswamy
I think you know we've already seen him
tie in some polls for a second and we've
seen in the prediction markets he's tied
for a second I think I think you give it
a week especially with this statement
Scott Adams just tweeted something like
is it just me or he did he do that
without notes there was that one point
where he accidentally forgot to say the
word from and then quickly caught it I
noticed that and I'm like he doesn't
have a script yeah when I heard that I'm
like there's no script there you see how
well spoken he is a guy like this
doesn't need a script
he said if we don't learn our mistakes
if we don't learn from our past mistakes
so he misspoke the word right well it's
from it makes you believe he's more
genuine because he's not going off a
script like every one of these other
politics unless he's so smart he has a
prompter but he intentionally he talked
to me like that seven years old yeah the
guy's amazing dude he's very got that I
don't know obviously than me I like I
almost want him to like join the unit
party just to get in so that he can
become the brilliant Visionary and
alterator that we need but I I don't
want to see him get lost to the universe
but that's what happens when you become
president you become the leader of the
military industrial complex and he's
willing he knows he's going to get
changed he said that to you Tim on the
culture War he's like I'm gonna go in
there I'm gonna be a different person
after eight years I know I'm willing I
was saying that I thought
he could not win Trump's the clear
front-runner Trump will be the nominee
at this point I'm thinking like Vivek
has has has defended the right
principles he's defended Trump he's
spoken clearly and truthfully and
honestly he's addressed every question
put before him I'm extremely impressed
with him and I think I think he's in
second place thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time